The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last
class, we introduced
thin-film technologies.
We described some of
their generic advantages
and disadvantages.
I showed that particular book
that's going around in the back
there, The Handbook of
Photovoltaics Science
and Engineering.
That describes several
of the technologies
that we're discussing
today and last class.
So last class we covered
general thin films
and cad-tel-- cadmium telluride.
Today we're going to be talking
about amorphous silicon, copper
indium gallium diselenide, and
the last material system, which
is actually more of a stack
or a composite of several.
Then we'll enter a debate,
which will be kind of fun.
So amorphous silicon-- we talked
about crystalline silicon.
Crystalline silicon is
the crystalline form
of the element known as
silicon, comprising a diamond
cubic crystal structure.
Amorphous silicon,
on the other hand,
is a very broad term
catching a range of materials
that lack long-range order.
Let me be a little
bit more specific.
Typically, there is some
semblance of short-range order
in these materials.
One can describe the
composition of amorphous silicon
using, say, for example,
a radial distribution
function-- the average distance
from one atom to the next.
And you have these
distribution functions
describing the material.
It gets a little
bit more tricky when
you try to define it on
a more detailed level,
with average number
of nearest neighbors,
the local configuration, the
number of stretched bonds
locally.
And the reality is that
with any amorphous material,
you can deposit a
range of materials.
It isn't just one
specific amorphous
silicon material that
you get every time.
Depending on your
deposition conditions,
depending on the pressure, and
the temperature, and the power,
during the PCVD-- the
plasma-enhanced chemical vapor
deposition-- you obtain a range
of amorphous silicon materials.
And within that
range, you can find
that the mobility
of charge carriers
can vary by several factors.
The mobility, I believe,
in amorphous silicon
can range easily between
0.001 and 0.1 centimeter
squared per volt second.
So that's two orders
of magnitude easily.
And I have heard of amorphous
silicon materials that
have gone as low as 10 to the
minus 4 centimeter squared
per volt second, and as
high as approaching 1.
So we have a range of material
qualities as a result,
and also a range of performance.
Likewise, there's a range
of stress in the film,
depending on how you deposit
your amorphous silicon.
So delamination is
of concern as well,
depending on how you deposit it.
And the challenges
from a material level
is getting consistent quality
material, high-quality material
every single deposition, and
overcoming certain degradation
modes that are present
in amorphous silicon,
not present in other material
systems-- certainly not present
in crystalline silicon.
For example, the
Staebler-Wronski defect
that's still up for some
debate as to what precisely
is the atomic nature
of that defect.
But it is known that when
one exposes amorphous silicon
to sunlight, that
the performance will
degrade with a
relatively quick time
constant over the period
of minutes and hours,
and finally stabilize.
So when you report
the cell performance
of an amorphous silicon cell,
it's always very important
to emphasize that this
is light-degraded or
light-stabilized
efficiency, as opposed
to the efficiency you get
when you take it straight out
of the deposition
chamber, and it
hasn't been exposed to high
amounts of sunlight yet.
In general, amorphous silicon
has low hole mobility.
Again, the precise root
cause on an atomic scale
for the low hole mobility
is still up for some debate.
There's a professor here
at MIT, Jeff Grossman,
who has performed a combination
of molecular dynamics
and density functional theory
to obtain amorphous silicon
samples in DFT.
And through those samples,
he and his colleagues
were able to determine that
the low hole mobility might
be caused by stretched
bonds, certain types
of stretched bonds, within
the amorphous silicon.
There are other hypotheses
out there as well
in the literature.
Finally, just getting a
uniform film deposition
at high speed-- that's
really key-- a high speed,
uniform deposition
of this layer has
proved challenging in
commercial production so far.
So all of this has combined
so that amorphous silicon
has received a lot of
attention, but hasn't
yet, in a massive way, been
economically successful.
This is a cross-section SCM of
an amorphous silicon device,
showing the TCO-- the
transparent conducting
oxide-- on the top.
The TCO was deposited
onto the glass,
which appears at the very
top underneath the scale bar.
The amorphous silicon layer
right here in the middle
is shown.
It is in a PIN structure.
So we've learned
about P-N junctions.
The I layer between
is an intrinsic layer,
meaning lightly doped.
And we'll see the band
diagram in the next slide.
The silver contact in the back
here extracting the charge
from the backside.
So this is an example of the
amorphous silicon technology.
Again, another cross-section
just for your reference,
showing the stack there.
OK, the PIN device
architecture-- right here
we can see the P plus layer,
or the P layer, the N layer,
and then the I here in
the middle-- the lightly
doped, intrinsic layer.
Note the band structure
or the band diagram,
how it's arranged.
And interestingly,
the layer thicknesses
here are on the order
of 300 nanometers
for the entire stack.
It's rather thin, typically
under a micron in thickness.
The reason it's very thin
is because amorphous silicon
absorbs light much, much better
than crystalline silicon.
For those who have a
solid-state physics background
and want to know the root cause
of that, I'll explain briefly.
For those who don't have the
background and can follow,
don't worry.
Plant a flag.
We'll come right back to it.
So in crystalline silicon,
we have crystal symmetry,
and hence we have momentum
conservation rules
when we excite charge carriers,
hence the indirect band gap
nature of crystalline silicon.
When we amorphize our
material, we no longer
have that crystal symmetry.
We no longer have
momentum conservation.
We can excite directly
from your valence band
into your conduction band.
So that, in a very
quick, hand-wavy way
is why amorphous silicon tends
to behave like a direct band
gap semiconductor,
absorbing light
extremely well with a very high
optical absorption coefficient.
Hence, instead of
100 microns, we
can get away with 300
nanometers of thickness.
All right, back to our flag.
We see here the PIN structure.
Everybody should be able to
follow along and understand
that if light excites a charge
carrier here in the middle,
the electrons will be swept the
right, the holes to the left.
And we'll have charge
separation occurring.
Sometimes, we can have a stack
of materials like shown here,
with varying band
gaps by, for example,
blending germanium into
the amorphous silicon.
This can modify the band
gap of the material.
And we can wind up
with a stack of layers,
or we could simply use two
layers of the same material.
We wouldn't necessarily be
able to absorb more efficiently
across the solar
spectrum, but we
would be able to increase the
voltage output of the device.
So there's a variety of
different amorphous silicon
shall we say designs
out there in the market.
Here's one example
of the triple stack.
We have amorphous
silicon here at the top,
with a large band gap.
The band gap is somewhere
in the range of 1.7 eV.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: I just have a
question of how that-- so
does the [INAUDIBLE]
pair have to go
to the interface between
the [INAUDIBLE] to separate?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah, so
in this particular case,
I believe this is
a dual terminal
device, which would be rather
tricky to perform an operation.
What you have to imagine--
this is right here
with very small perturbation.
If you imagine it being
biased in sunlight,
then you can easily see how a
larger voltage would result.
Right here, you can imagine
a two-terminal device where
you extract charge
from here and here,
or perhaps a
four-terminal device--
which is less common because it
requires more metal contacts.
But that would contact
the device here, here,
again here, and here.
So you'd have the two
devices contacted.
If you have a
two-terminal device,
one can typically think about
it as adding the voltages
together.
Then the current would
be limited by the worst
performer of those two.
And that's why you
have this thinner
than that one over
here, because we
know that the light tends to
be absorbed preferentially
near the front surface.
We're absorbing an
equivalent number of photons
in this thickness and
in that thickness.
So the currents
tend to be matched.
So that's why I would guess,
given the geometry of the fact
that we have silver in the
back and TCO in the front,
and no explicit contacts
here in the middle,
that this is a two-terminal
device as opposed to a four.
This stack right here
is representative
of what is commercialized by Uni
Solar, a company in Michigan,
where we have an
amorphous silicon
layer on the top, wide
band gap semiconductor--
somewhere in the range
of 1.7 to 1.9 eV,
depending on the
deposition conditions.
Again, I mentioned that
amorphous silicon is really
a range of materials.
There is no one
amorphous silicon.
Depending on the
density of atoms
inside of the amorphous
infrastructure
and their local configuration,
you can vary the properties
quite a bit.
So the band gap can
vary, but typically it's
in the range of 1.7 to 1.9 eV.
Blending in germanium--
germanium being a bigger atom--
tends to reduce the band
gap of the material.
And you have successively
higher concentrations
moving toward the
back, so the band gap
shrinks from front to back.
And you can wind up
with a stack like this.
And this is an example here
of a three-cell stack, where
you have the combined
quantum efficiency
and the individual quantum
efficiencies of each
of the sub-cells, showing you
how you can really fill up
the entire solar spectrum
using a combination
of these materials.
Unfortunately, despite
all these efforts,
the material is still
affected by what's
called the Staebler-Wronski
effect in honor
of the people who
initially determined it.
The Staebler-Wronski effect
typically manifests itself
as a degradation of
material performance
as a function of time.
It's also known that as the
layer thickness increases,
the predominance of this
effect also increases,
and its impact also increases.
So it manifests itself as
a reduction of the fill
factor, a reduction
of performance,
and we see the trade-offs
during device design
of amorphous silicon.
So I would say, the essence
of amorphous silicon
is that it's a very
promising material,
has a wide degree of tunability.
But the low hole mobility
limits its performance
to somewhere around 10% for
just a single amorphous silicon
layer, and in the low
teens for the stacks
of multiple materials,
one on top of another.
And this right here is
showing an interesting effect.
When you begin heating
up your substrate,
when you're depositing
amorphous silicon,
you have amorphous material.
If you heat up your substrate
to too high of a temperature
during the deposition
process-- and this is also
impacted by the concentration
of silane gas to hydrogen ratio
during the deposition
process-- one
can obtain a phase transition
from amorphous material
into what's called
microcrystalline material.
That's shown at the very top.
a-Si stands for amorphous
silicon, mu-Si for
microcrystalline silicon.
Microcrystalline silicon is
right at the phase transition
between an amorphous silicon
and a crystalline variant
polycrystalline
variant of silicon.
And in some cases,
it can actually
contain a mixture
of both amorphous
and crystalline regions.
And so it's very tricky to
nail to the position conditions
just right.
Somebody along the
way figured out--
wait a second-- we
can actually use
this microcrystalline
silicon to our advantage,
and stack a layer of
microcrystalline silicon
on the bottom, put a layer of
amorphous silicon on the top.
And that was called a micromorph
technology as a result.
And there are companies that
have commercialized micromorph.
So the micromorph technology
commercialized by Oerlikon
and previously by a company
in the United States
called Applied Materials.
And we'll get to that in
a couple slides as well.
This right here is a brief
slide just addressing
the issue of how
growth conditions can
impact material quality.
There are a number of growth
parameters, shall we say,
that impact whether you
obtain an amorphous material
with high mobility,
with low mobility,
a microcrystalline material,
nanocrystalline material,
and so forth.
And if you're interested
in more details,
these NREL reports from the
late 1990s and early 2000s,
mid 2000s, are really a
treasure trove of information,
if you really want to
get up to speed quickly
on how to grow high-quality
amorphous silicon layers.
OK, so these are
record amorphous
silicon cell efficiencies.
This, I believe, was
from the Martin Green
tables that come out each
half year in Progress
in Photovoltaics.
So he and his colleagues
produce an article every half
of a year in Progress
in Photovoltaics,
describing the record
efficiencies of lab size
cells-- maybe a centimeter
squared-- all the way up
to full-size modules.
So we have here
amorphous silicon
and the blended amorphous
silicon germanium,
or SiGe for short.
People sometimes call
silicon germanium SiGe.
So we have a variety of
different types shown here,
and the areas of the
devices shown here.
I would caution
over-interpretation
of the very small area devices.
If you're at 0.25
centimeters, you're
at a very small linear dimension
along the side of the cell,
and you can wind up being
impacted by edge effects.
Sometimes this is
the active area
of a much larger
device, where they've
shrunken down the aperture.
But depending on the
texturization of the surface,
you still get light
trapping and, essentially,
a larger active area than what
is actually being shaded off.
So I would caution you against
over-interpreting these very
small area measurements.
At 1 centimeter squared larger,
you're typically in a regime
where the results
are more believable.
The Jse's shown here,
Voc's shown here.
Note in certain
cases, the Voc you
would expect from
amorphous silicon,
if it's a band gap
of 1.7 eV, you'd
expect a Voc somewhere in
the range of maybe 1.4 volts.
And sometimes you get
much lower than that.
Likewise, the short
circuit current
is rather low, say, compared
to a crystalline silicon
device because of
that higher band gap--
the inability to capture some
of those lower energy photons.
And so the record
single amorphous
silicon device
performance somewhere
buttressing up against
10%-- not quite.
And then if you combine
different layers into a stack,
for example here, you can
move into the low teens
for your performance.
Flag that-- these numbers here.
We're going to get
back to this, and use
that to understand why
some of the technologies
didn't make it to
commercialization.
This represents the largest
scale attempt to commercialize
amorphous silicon technology.
This was a turnkey line.
Let's start from over here.
This is a human being seated
at a computer-- two humans.
This pod right
here-- this machine--
represents one of these
little components right here
that fits into a much
larger assembly line.
This is the PCVD
reactor, actually.
I believe there
were seven of them
attached to each of these
little pods right here.
So this the plasma-enhanced
chemical vapor deposition
reactors were depositing
microcrystalline silicon
and amorphous silicon
onto sheets of glass
that were as large as you
could possibly transport.
Does anybody just happen
to know the number
off the top of their head?
What is the largest
sheet of glass
that you can physically
transport, say
in commercial form, such
that you could buy it
in bulk without custom design
of the Pilkington float glass
process?
AUDIENCE: It's as big as the
cross-sectional area of that.
PROFESSOR: It's about,
yeah, yeah, definitely.
That's a good place to start.
It's actually
dictated by what can
fit on some of the trucks
that transport the glass back
and forth.
You ever seen the glass
transport trucks with the sides
where they put the
panes of glass in?
And they have the chassis
of the truck like so,
and the glass along the edge.
It's around 3 by 3.3 meters.
And so these deposition
systems could incorporate
huge sheets of glass.
And they would leave
it up to the customer
whether they wanted
to quarter them
and make reasonable-sized
modules, or whether they
want the full-size
module and have
to use cranes to
install them, which
would reduce the labor
content of installation,
but would shift the burden
onto the automation.
So you see the panes
of glass coming along,
pre-cleaning, and eventually
insertion to these devices.
Why so many of those devices?
Why so many PCVD reactors like
little piglets around a pod
here?
Each of these reactors
would have a cycle time
somewhere on the order
of a few 10s of minutes--
so my estimate would be
somewhere between 20 and 30
minutes, maybe up to 40.
Because the
microcrystalline silicon
layer just took so
long to deposit.
But without that
microcrystalline layer,
it was difficult to
reach 10% efficiency.
With just the amorphous
silicon layer,
the efficiencies were in
the range of 6% to 7%.
And if you start doing
calculations for a 6% or 7%
module, you realize very quickly
that the cost of the glass,
and the encapsulants, and
everything else adds up,
because your device is
so low in efficiency
that you need more encapsulant,
more gas, more labor, more
installation to produce
a panel to produce
the same amount of power.
And as a result, the
system cost was very high.
This technology couldn't compete
once the Chinese production
started really ramping
up in the market,
and decreasing the cost of
traditional crystalline silicon
modules.
And the SunFab Project,
which was Applied Materials
name for this amorphous silicon
line-- or micromorph line,
in reality-- was shut
down relatively recently,
about a year ago,
when it I realized
that this was no
longer commercially
viable in the face of some
of the low-cost competition
from crystalline silicon.
All that could change very
quickly, if somehow one of you
were to develop a way to, say,
double the record efficiency
number.
So if someone were to figure
out why exactly hole mobility is
so low, impairing
transport inside
of these materials,
in principle one
could then envision rolling
it out into the SunFab line.
There's already a turnkey
production equipment
that's been built by Applied
Materials, ready to go.
And you're off and running.
So that's an
opportunity out there.
This lists some of the
commercialization attempts.
And the bottom line
at the end of the day
was that 6% modules were too
inefficient to be profitable,
unless you reach scales
of, say, gigawatts.
And believe it or not, there
was one company out there called
OptiSolar, the business
plan was literally
to scale up to a gigawatt
faster than everybody else.
And even though it
was lower performance,
the sheer size and scale of
the manufacturing facility
would reduce the cost
of the amorphous silicon
relative to the crystalline
silicon competition.
Unfortunately, OptiSolar
didn't make it, either.
So the companies
that are left today
producing amorphous
silicon include Oerlikon.
This is a Swiss company that
produces turnkey equipment,
and Uni Solar, which is
selling the actual modules
of amorphous silicon.
They have a nice roll to
roll deposition process
on these stainless steel foils.
Very nice factory--
believe it was
toured by several members of
our current administration.
And they're still going.
AUDIENCE: Sorry--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the roll
that that person's
holding-- what is he holding?
PROFESSOR: I usually
think, based on the color,
that this already has amorphous
silicon deposited onto it.
But it could be at some
intermediate phase.
I don't know for that specific
roll, but in principle,
yes, at the end of the
manufacturing line,
they'll have a full stack--
the triple amorphous
silicon and then the two
layers of SiGe beneath it.
AUDIENCE: What's--
the base is flexible,
so what's the thing that the
film is deposited on, do you
know?
PROFESSOR: So what
they incorporate
their flexible material
into typically,
one of their products
is roof shingle.
That looks very similar to a
standard, asphalt-based roof
shingle.
And it is very nice building
integrated technology.
I happened to see one back
when I was a graduate student,
and I was inspired by the
building integrated potential
there.
So there are attempts to
integrate amorphous silicon
into regular crystalline
silicon technology, as well.
Turns out amorphous silicon
passivates the surfaces
very nicely.
And you can create what's called
a HIT cell structure, which
is a heterojunction with
a thin intrinsic layer,
using a silicon substrate.
Typically what's used
is an n-type base.
And then the amorphous
silicon layers
are deposited on either side.
And that device
is currently being
commercialized by a company
called Sanyo in Japan.
The patents for the
base HIT cell structure
expire very soon, if they
haven't expired already.
And so there is a fair amount
of interest-- several companies
out there right now attempting
to reproduce this process.
But it is fairly tricky.
And again, a lot
of it boils down
to managing the
interfaces-- making
sure the interface between the
crystal silicon and amorphous
silicon are of high quality.
So we have our HIT
cell structure here.
Let me hop over to the
last thin-film materials
so we have adequate
time for our debates.
The copper indium gallium
diselenide, or SIGS for short--
this is a quaternary
phase, sometimes comprised
of even five elements.
But let's show this is
the chalcopyrite structure
right here, with copper shown in
black, indium or gallium shown
in gray-- typically there's
some blend between the two--
and the chalcogen-- the
selenium or sulfur--
shown in the white right
here, typically selenium.
So we have here an example
of the crystal structure.
As I understand the situation,
this crystal structure
came into being because copper
sulfide demonstrated potential
as a photovoltaic material
early on, say in the late 1970s,
early 1980s.
There were attempts to grow
high-performance copper sulfide
cells.
They failed because
copper electromigrated.
In the presence of an
electric field, copper,
a very small ion
far to the right
on the 3-d series
of elements-- so
if you look at the
transition metals,
copper is on the
far right, meaning
you're adding more and more
and more protons to the nucleus
as you go from left
to right, and you're
pulling the outer shell in.
So if you look at atomic
radius going from left to right
in the periodic
table, you'll see
that the atoms tend to shrink.
So copper, being on
the far right-hand side
of the 3-d elemental series,
has a smaller atomic radius
compared to, say, iron,
or manganese, or titanium.
And as a result, it
could move fairly easily
throughout the lattice if it
is present in a charged state--
if you have, say, copper plus--
and a large electric field
distributed across a thin
film solar cell device.
So copper sulfide devices ended
up degrading quickly over time.
And it was realized that
some heavier elements
needed to be included
to stabilize the crystal
structure.
So in the lab, the reason why
SIGS-- this particular material
right here-- is so interesting
is because in the laboratory,
efficiencies on the order
of 20% have been achieved.
For large area-- you'll have
to correct this number right
here-- you can increase that
to 15% plus-- 15.7% in fact,
over large area devices.
That's a very recent result
coming out of MiaSole,
a company in California.
There are dozens of
startup companies
focused on SIGS development.
And it is a very
challenging problem
to get the stoichiometry
right, and to passivate
the defects inside the
structure, including surfaces.
Where many companies
fail or fall
short is getting the
stoichiometry just right
over a large area.
It's as simple as a
manufacturing challenge.
The idealized structure of
these thin-film devices--
you have your SIGS layer
right here in the middle.
In this case, it's
shown as CIS or cis,
but you can add gallium as well.
Typically, gallium
is blended in.
Moly-- molybdenum-- back
contact on the glass--
the glass in this case is just
the support for the structure.
Molybdenum here would
be non-transparent.
It'd be an opaque layer.
The cadmium sulfide
on the front side
here forms a very nice interface
with the SIGS layer underneath,
preventing any interface
damage or any segregation,
say, of gallium to
the surface here.
And then the zinc
oxide layer on the top,
which serves as the buffer
window layer, depending, is
then deposited on the
cadmium sulfide layer.
And eventually charge
is brought away.
This right here is another
three-dimensional rendition
of the same.
What is unique about each
of those dozens of startup
companies is the process in
which they deposit the SIGS
layer, typically.
So you have companies
like MiaSole
that are invested in
sputtering of SIGS.
You have companies
like Nanosolar
that are invested in
ink-based printing of SIGS.
So they print an ink
down, and then they
sinter the ink to
form the layer.
And like those two, there are
many other companies out there
that are depositing SIGS in
some way, shape, or form.
The folks at NREL
seem to be more
in favor of thermal evaporation
based process for SIGS.
Many of the more successful
industrial renditions of SIGS
right now-- at least the ones
that appear most promising--
are using other
deposition methods.
So you'll see a
variety out there,
of deposition methods
for SIGS technology.
And one of the things
to keep track of,
as you watch and monitor
all these startup companies,
is to bin them by their process,
and to begin to discern trends.
As we start to see some market
leaders evolve in the sector,
begin to discern which
technologies are the most
appropriate, perhaps for
large-scale deposition
of this material system.
Interfaces are critical.
Here are some examples of
attempts at mapping out--
and quite successful attempts at
mapping out the, shall we say,
the band diagram of a
SIGS-based solar cell.
One thing to keep in mind
is that, just like amorphous
silicon represents a
broad class of materials,
SIGS also represents a broad
class of stoichiometries,
meaning the ratio of
indium to gallium,
the ratio of-- if you include
it at all-- sulfur to selenium
is critical in determining
the properties of both
the bulk and the surfaces.
Typically at the surfaces,
you will get termination
by one atom, one atomic
species or another-- one
elemental species or another.
And that will determine,
to a large degree,
the electronic quality
of that surface.
So for a long time
in literature,
you had debating world views of
what the band diagram of a SIGS
device really looked like.
And it turned out a lot
of people were right.
They just had varying
starting materials.
So they were comparing
apples to oranges.
The thing that keeps
people going with SIGS
is that in the
laboratory, efficiencies,
I believe, now up to 21%
have been demonstrated.
So that is really encouraging.
People-- venture capitalists--
will look at this
and say, wow, with
those high efficiencies,
you could really
make solar cheap.
The amount of, again,
glass, encapsulants,
labor, and so forth that you
have to have for watt peak
is lower, because
the cell can perform
at a higher performance.
But the downside is, there's a
gap between-- a substantial gap
between-- what is commercially
manufacturable today
and that record
efficiency device.
Sometimes the practical
matters of commercialization
are the ones that
impede a technology
from getting to market.
And I have a modicum of
faith that SIGS will make it.
But if it fails to reach
its true market potential,
if it fails to realize
its dream of becoming
a significant fraction of
all solar panels produced,
it will most likely be because
of these process engineering
issues associated with
depositing over a large area,
coupled to the scientific gap
in managing interfaces properly.
So that's the story
of SIGS in a nutshell.
There are some minor
issues, shall we say,
associated with cadmium.
There are attempts to go to
an all zinc oxide or maybe
a graded zinc oxysulfide
buffering window layer here
in the front to get
rid of the cadmium.
We'll discuss that shortly.
And I would say that's
probably the biggest
near-term challenge.
With the removal of cadmium,
you can access more markets.
And secondly, SIGS
does contain indium,
which is not in an infinite
supply in Earth's crust.
It's debatable how much of
an issue that really is.
And we'll get to that
in our discussions
as well, in our debates.
SIGS commercialization--
several startup companies
and I would say a lot
of promising research
and development
going on right now.
This particular
technology right here--
let's keep this company
nameless for now.
This company represents
some of the difficulties
in ramping up large area SIGS.
They deposit it sometimes
over large areas,
but would achieve
inhomogeneous results.
And so the ultimate form
factor for the devices
was to chop them
up into areas that
are not too dissimilar from
an actual crystalline silicon
device.
So to chop up their layers into
individual, discrete cells,
and then to connect them--
solder them together,
much like a crystalline
silicon device
would be put together
inside a module.
So the dream of having this
inline, thin-film process
roll to roll was reaching an
abrupt wall, shall we say,
in the development process
because of the lack
of large-scale uniformity.
So you need to chop them up
into smaller units, which
would add to the cost,
which would decrease
the module performance as
well, and now you have gaps
in between the cells.
So it just goes to show
the difficulty of bringing
a new technology to market.
And hopefully, they're
doing better now.
Lots of promising news for SIGS,
like this particular article--
"The Rise of SIGS,
Finally?" question mark.
There has always
been a lot of promise
in the realm of SIGS because
of the high performance
and high efficiencies reached.
The big question is,
can you accomplish this
at large scale for
large area modules?
That's been the big challenge
so far-- and of course,
materials availability.
So let me pause right here.
What I'm going to do-- we
are going to shift gears.
And for the next 20
minutes-- unfortunately,
not half an hour, but
for the next 20 minutes--
we are going to
enter debate mode.
What we're going to do is divide
the group into-- this group
right here-- into
your project teams.
And you'll cluster
together and work together
on this next exercise.
So for the very
beginning, we're going
to have the cadmium
telluride debate.
That will be debate number one.
We'll be discussing the
pros and cons of cad-tel.
Keep in mind that First
Solar, a gigawatt company,
meaning one of the largest
companies in the world,
and certainly the largest
company in the United States,
is going full force producing
cadmium telluride modules.
The debate question that
you'll be faced with is, is it
a good investment for
the United States?
Say, for example, you're
in charge of US government
research and development funds.
Should you be putting
your money into cad-tel?
Or should you be putting your
money into something else?
And we'll have two sides
of the debate-- one
that will defend cad-tel
and say, no, it's
a very promising technology.
We should be going all in.
And the other side
that will be adopting
the counter argument
saying, well, cad-tel
has these concerns.
Perhaps we should be
looking elsewhere to invest.
And that's the debate number
one-- cad-tel, no cad-tel.
For the folks working on
earth-abundant materials,
the second debate will be
focused on that question.
Recently, there's
been a lot of interest
in developing earth-abundant
alternatives to, say, SIGS,
because of the indium
content, and cad-tel because
of the tellurium content.
And there's been a huge
amount of momentum behind it.
But there are few
naysayers out there
who say, well, wait a second.
We've always come
up against shortages
of one kind or another, since
the days of Malthus's warning
about the limits of population
growth because of limited food
supply.
But then we developed
fertilizers.
And that overcame that limit.
Likewise, in these
resource abundance issues,
I'm sure we're going to
find some new way to extract
the metals.
We'll find a way around it.
We'll discover new
deposits and so forth.
You hear similar arguments in
the peak oil debate, right?
And so what I'd like to do
is to set up two teams there
as well to debate this
particular question.
[APPLAUSE]
And we furthermore
recognize that several
of these issues
that might appear
black and white, in reality
have many shades of gray in PV.
This cad-tel debate
is one of them.
We'll hear the second
debate the next time.
And anything from should we
invest in silicon technology
or should we develop thin films
will have these shades of gray
as well.
So it's important to
recognize that simple fact
as you gain maturity, and shades
of gray in your own ability
to argument one side or another.
So thank you, and we'll
see us on Thursday.